Bethesda brought its big guns to e3 last
year with its inaugural press conference
with fallout 4 doom and Dishonored 2 at
the show and lucky for us it looks like
they're returning to the premiere video
game show for a second round on Monday
the maryland-based company announced
that its e3 briefing will be held sunday
june twelfth starting at seven p.m.
pacific Bethesda's briefing at e3 2015
was the company's first-ever
presentation at the annual show during
the event but that's the showcase its
aforementioned flagship franchises among
other games but that didn't say what it
plans to show at e3 2016 the image shown
in the announcement contains references
to the fallout and elder scrolls
franchises among others before today it
wasn't exactly clear if Bethesda would
actually have another showing at this
year's e3 but does the marketing
executive Pete Hines said last year I
don't know if we'll do one again 2015
felt like the right time to do this kind
of thing Bethesda's first-ever III
briefing last year was also held on a
Sunday evening which before this
publisher came along was not usually on
the schedule this year however there
will be at least two on Sunday as
electronic arts is also planning its
first-ever EA play event for Sunday
afternoon so what do you hope to see at
the conference fallout 4 DLC more of
this honor two or maybe even something
entirely new
you